hello and welcome to this video playing
Eddie muscle on some of this ring the
bell and get plated last time my
livestream ok zone he was generous
giving me the bishop pair let's see if I
can open up the position eight ok
alright so it's not playing g5 yeah I
cannot believe that I Queen you ate this
kind of stuff maybe out that that's
possible
okay see salmon is attacked and night
except six is also ok why isn't that
giving away Scotty night be five Wow to
595 Quincy five hmm Roxy and queen is
seven how well the thing is
strategically i'm also in fantastic
shape if i don't take the poem but it's
just a bit too too tempting not to take
it yeah whatever you can say about is
please play his plane quickly okay so
this one
some just Roxy one may be roped YouTube
do you won something like that
okay add Bishop to is somewhat somewhat
strange ok so push up here right mmm why
is he going to c6 know
between a form a beacon age 3 King g1
f3s check on the a check on e4 so that
doesn't work check
f3 2824 Queen f3 so f3 doesn't work and
now he thinks starts to think and
wonders what's going on okay Queen to d4
maybe just like that I cannot check this
is covered go into the fourth 3d7 and i
have two queens i'm going to made so
look see am he has to ice to do a thing
go back
don't really see an adulterer rook c8 d7
look t8 I don't see a win
what wow
if this is working all the while okay um
well I have to take it anyway check and
now what's going on here King you have
three Queen takes King e4
check
can't believe that this is a perpetual
maybe it is so good so what's the check
here ok let's play it and then see what
happens check time warning
check Sloane didn't OD to counter checks
I Quincy for King III check black
resigns ok now tho those instantly was
always tricky to play every day they
would have a huge advantage on the clock
and you have to end the game somewhere
yeah ok so here this is already very
nice for white ok the computer is is
giving you win already which is maybe
objectively true what still has to be
played you know ok this it gives away
material looks e8 it's interesting what
the engine wants to do it I was thinking
just take here I probably would have
taken and then decide what to do maybe
it's something like f for you take those
pawns and try to open up even more for
the bishops now ok the engine likes this
but it thinks so it evaluates this is
even stronger
hmm and maybe don't quite understand it
to be honest why this is better I mean
the lion is better the line that the
engine is giving understand that it is
created clearly a nice brook f8 Knight
f6 GTA exam and something else that I've
form and maybe this is even stronger
that looks pretty terrible ok so here I
decided to grab but this isn't a clear
decision okay the computer wants to play
Bishop b2 yeah I I kind of had this
suspicion during the game because
strategically this is so good for white
you don't have to grab this pawn I mean
just put this on the long diagonal
player for and bust open this is even
stronger probably than grabbing the
material yeah because he he gets some
sort of activity here and it's not not
that easy to play that's the 1.6 so
let's see if i did a relatively decent
job here yeah i wanted to get this just
seems this as a draw funny enough Bishop
b5 is stronger so ff4 actually wins for
him oh my god I didn't see that at all
so takes Queen g4 is winning for black
oh my god whoa yeah this is a this is
NAT we have three as well Wow yeah I can
do this but I only thought about Queen
h3 which I think doesn't do anything but
Queen g4 is brutal yeah this is this
would have been this would have been the
moment I'm to invest a second at least
just out of moving everything instantly
twinsies form no I didn't see that I was
only thinking about Queen Queen age
three stack and this is indeed winning
yeah he has to probably go rook c8 that
doesn't do a group c 8 and now I mean XD
78 I know something something like that
but this is not super trivial with no
time on the clock I mean I don't win in
the next couple of moves at least check
this i feel shouldn't wish I running up
the board is probably probably easiest
check and this is a meeting in a couple
of moves okay how about a tough tougher
game cell Quincy for that would have
been a real shocker okay well thanks for
watching